buenas tardes desde londres por ser el
día que marca el inicio de esta guerra
de las malvinas o en inglés folk land
island no se ha realizado ningún evento
especial público en esta guerra que
murieron más de 900 personas pero la
gran celebración será el 14 de junio
cuando marcará el 40 aniversario de la
del fin de la guerra de las malvinas con
el triunfo británico sobre la argentina
a través de 'twitter' el primer ministro
boris johnson el ministro de defensa
como lo mencionas la ministra es de
exteriores han enviado un mensaje de
agradecimiento a los veteranos de esta
guerra y a quienes perdieron la vida
defendiendo la soberanía de estas islas
bueno luisa y en este momento de la
historia se marcó además una inflexión
en el entonces gobierno de la primera
ministra margaret thatcher
sí sin duda sin la guerra de las
malvinas definitivamente el gobierno de
margaret thatcher no hubiera durado más
de una década estuvo 11 años en downing
street y es que justamente esta guerra
fue una inyección
de popularidad para la conocida dama de
hierro que en ese momento vivía
justamente una de las crisis económicas
más fuertes que ha tenido este país pero
también significa una recuperación del
orgullo británico dado que desde la
segunda guerra mundial este país estaba
prácticamente en una crisis desde
entonces las relaciones entre la
argentina y el reino unido- son
cordiales pese a que aún hoy los dos
países reclaman la sobre soberanía sobre
estas islas